film adaptations of video games are more
often than not
unsuccessful but there's hope on the
horizon here's a rundown of the new
mortal kombat trailer
and the small details that may have
slipped past you in the midst of its
ultra-violent glory
right off the bat the trailer for 2021's
mortal kombat
gives audiences a good look at one of
the property's most prolific
and popular entities sub-zero portrayed
here by joe taslim
throughout the trailer's run time
sub-zero gives everyone a bad day
naturally during his rampage sub-zero
utilizes his cryomancer abilities
freezing his opponents and using ice
based weaponry against them he even
creates an ice wall which gamers can
perform when they play a sub-zero in
mortal kombat 11.
one interesting thing to note about this
particular sub-zero incarnation
is that his real name is bihan a fact
that director
simon mcquoid revealed in his trailer
breakdown for ign
for long time players of the mortal
kombat video games the name bihar should
ring some bells
he was the first to take on the sub-zero
mantle bihan appeared under the frosty
alias only in the first mortal combat
game
where he quickly met his demise and
granted his younger brother kwai liang
the chance to follow in his footsteps
however bihan eventually rose from the
grave as the villainous wraith
noobs cybot and continues to wreak havoc
under this dark persona to this day
mother would be so proud
shifting gears away from an established
name in the mortal kombat universe the
film's trailer also introduces a fresh
face to spruce up the decades-old roster
of combatants
carl jung played by lewis tan is a down
on his luck yet
experienced cage fighter who's called to
join the legendary mortal kombat
tournament
courtesy of the mysterious dragon shaped
birth mark on his chest
cole is framed as the film's main
protagonist and only enters a
competition to protect his loved ones
making him mortal combats emotional core
mcquoid explained to ign why he and his
team felt the need to include kol young
in the mortal kombat reboot saying we
felt it was okay to bring in a new
character
given that mortal kombat has over the
years introduced new characters quite a
bit
he reassured everyone that cole doesn't
detract from the slew of legacy
characters mccoy also expanded on the
newcomer's function as a storytelling
device
and how it should affect viewers who
haven't stepped into the mortal kombat
world before
adding as cole learns the audience
learns and it helps us bring in those
fresh sets of ice
a long standing aspect of the mortal
kombat mythos there's a diverse range of
realms
and the frequent universe altering
conflicts between their inhabitants
locations like netherrealm chaos realm
earth realm
and more have hosted many of the canon's
brutal wars
and the upcoming film doesn't have any
desire to hide their existence
in the mortal kombat trailer fans catch
a brief glimpse of outworld
a realm governed by shao khan the
footage shows the character molina
walking through the land
appearing to be a realistic take on the
barren yet mountainous wasteland
gamers have come to recognize whether or
not any other realms will appear in
mortal kombat
is up for debates but it's surely a
possibility speaking to ign about what
went into bringing out world to life for
his mortal combat adaptation
mccoyd revealed that he quote wanted to
bring the realism and an authenticity
and the non-vfx feel to these unreal
worlds
to do so the director and his team
managed to find an area on earth
that fit the look and feel of the famous
fantasy location
the director explained he shot this in a
disused coal mine in the middle of
australia
he also cited how important it was to
express legitimacy of outworld's
aesthetic
and how surprisingly few digital
enhancements were needed to bring it to
life
for the majority of the mortal kombat
trailer franchise favorite sonia blade
provides narration over various clips
during her narration she brings up an
ancient legend about a tournament of
champions
that urges the selected participants to
fight in the name of mortal combat
in the games the event was created to
ensure outworld's power didn't grow too
strong
begging the questions it's a realm once
again threatening the sanctity of the
cosmos and if so who will bravely
attempt to stop it
to answer the first question the trailer
for 2021's mortal kombat provides a
couple of hints as to who could be
responsible for the takeover
outworld's ruler xiao khan isn't shown
in the flesh
but a statue of him makes a cameo in the
trailer beyond shao khan they're very
much alive shang tsun
accompanied by his forearms champion
goro is a logical pick
the soul-stealing warlock is no stranger
to stirring up trouble in the mk
universe
becoming one of its most nefarious
villains over the years
and know a taste of things to come of
course what would the forces of evil be
without the forces of good to oppose
them the trailer also features a handful
of other iconic mortal kombat characters
who will also join the fray to varying
degrees
about halfway through the mortal kombat
movie trailer earthrealm's champions are
introduced in small vignettes
accompanied by voiceovers
there's sonja blade liu kang jax and of
course kano
who has a long bitter rivalry with sonia
and is usually a villain in the mortal
kombat
universe this little baby brings back
memories now doesn't it
what you used it to knife your mother in
the back but in the forthcoming film
kano is now a sort of good guy kano
doesn't introduce himself like the
others do
instead sonia does the job in voice over
while viewers see footage of kano
shooting a red laser out of one of his
eyes it lasts for only a couple of
seconds
but kano's laser eye holds a lot of
weight in the mortal kombat world
in the games kano is usually depicted as
having a partial metal face plate
that covers one of his eyes he had the
face plate implanted at a cybernetic
enhancement
following an injury jax inflicted upon
him before the start of the mortal
kombat game series
and it's outfitted with an infrared
laser over his eye
allowing him to do some serious damage
when battling his opponents
the new movie version of kano doesn't
have the faceplate
but does have the laser eye which
suggests that this ability
didn't come about the same way plus
considering kano is also being portrayed
as an anti-hero in 2021's mortal kombat
film
it's even more unlikely that he gained
his laser beam shooting eye
after getting into a fight with jax fans
will just have to wait to see the movie
themselves
to learn what kano's new cinematic
backstory will be
maybe he and the good guys will all be
friends
[Music]
closer to the end of the film's trailer
luke yang is seen summoning balls of
fire to his hands
letting out a determined battle scream
before he slams his hand down
and lets a trail of fire snake its way
across the ground in front of him
until it grows into a massive flaming
dragon video game fans will recognize
this as a take on liu kang's dragon form
one of his signature moves in the
franchise immortal combat 11
it comes as a fatal blow which sees a
flaming dragon appear behind his
opponent
but more often luke yang himself morphs
into a giant dragon to finish off his
opponents
there have been several variations of
liu kyung's dragon bites fatality over
the years
from a simple green dragon that jumps
torsos to a black-scaled recreation
of the iconic mortal kombat symbol
itself whatever form this power takes on
the movie
one thing's for sure it's going to be
unique
in some of the mortal kombat trailers
most exciting moments we're treated to a
condensed version of hanzo hasashi's
metamorphosis into scorpion
he's first shown slinging around his
trusty kunai for the first time
taking out a horde of bad guys in the
woods the next time viewers see him he
is engulfed in his signature hellfire
and
darning his samurai inspired armor ready
for battle against his arch enemies
sub-zero
the trailer includes a snippet of their
clash including the utterance of
scorpion's most famous line
considering that is one of mk's tent
bowl figures getting scorpion right in
live action was of the utmost importance
to mccoyd
that included sticking the landing with
his origin and transformation
which the director hoped to chronicle
throughout the movie mccoy told ign
what i wanted to do was literally show
scorpion being born
and the ingredients and how he comes
about the director went on to discuss
the opening fight sequence featuring
hasashi
he described it as quote brutal and
nasty
and based on the clips from the trailer
that assessment isn't too far off
it's no secret that the mortal kombat
video games aren't for the faint of
heart
they're gory gruesome and sometimes
cringe-worthy and that reputation
doesn't come from simple side-scrolling
punches and kicks
fatalities moves unique to each
character that spotlight mutilating
match ending animations
are a bloody staple of the ip given
their cinematic nature
it should come as no surprise that
they're included in the upcoming mortal
kombat movie
mccoy told ign that fatalities were
always going to be a part of the movie
confirming that everyone involved in the
making of mortal kombat was on board
with their inclusion from the top down
even still he admitted there's certainly
restrictions on what you can do
and some of the restrictions are sort of
strange and surprising and some of them
are kind of obvious
the director noted that the goal was to
quote push it to the limit
but he didn't want to include such
graphic scenes without necessary context
or story weight to them
from fan favorite characters to
recognizable locales the mortal kombat
trailer has it all
if nothing else at least it gives
everyone multiple points to speculate on
in the weeks before
the film opens to the public check out
one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]